in fact I had a lady who lit up her
cigarette in the middle of my interview
and I said you know as a doctor I cannot
abide this bad behavior in she said to
me oh yeah what are you gonna do about
it
hi I'm Ted baliker with reason TV and
today I'll be speaking with dr. Stephen
Coles
Coles is an expert in the science of
longevity and a lecturer in the
Department of Chemistry and biochemistry
at the Institute of molecular biology at
UCLA can you in a nutshell tell me about
your research oh about 15 years ago I
got interested in understanding human
aging and I said who were the oldest
humans because they have done something
special they have escaped from the
conventional causes of death like heart
disease the number one killer or cancer
stroke or diabetes or even Alzheimer's
disease and it turns out that there are
88 living super centenarians so that
would be people at least 110 at least
110 and sometimes 115 or even 120 in
fact the world's oldest person when she
died in 1997 as Jean comet a French lady
was a hundred and twenty-two so she is
our Guinness Book of Records you know
maximum human lifespan in the question
that everybody I'm sure always ask you
is what are these super centenarians
doing right I found that they were all
different one from another
they had practically nothing in common
they were in different religions and
different occupations but the one sort
of common theme was that they had long
lived relatives so their parents were
long lived and their siblings their
brothers and sisters were long lived and
so I said you know it's gotta be in the
DNA it's got to be in the genes they
tend not to take vitamins they do tend
to indulge in bad habits they they smoke
in the error like when my parents lived
everybody smoked so that's not unusual
but some of these people smoked heavily
in fact I had a lady who lit up her
cigarette in the middle of
interview and I said you know as a
doctor I cannot abide this bad behavior
and she said to me oh yeah what are you
gonna do about it she was a 111 they get
away with this bad behavior because
their genes protect them but what does
that say to to us normal people who or
us average people who don't have super
centenarians in our family tree are we
just tinkering at the margins if we're
worrying about I mean certainly avoid
smoking wear your seatbelt get some
exercise but to what extent is that
what's the magnitude there versus just
genetics if you did nothing else but
look at your family tree to see what the
longevity profile was of your parents or
aunts and uncles and so forth your
grandparents and if you had no extra
advantage in longevity for any of those
first-degree relatives then your oth
out of luck because there's nothing you
can do by taking extra vitamins or so
you don't ever just eat that bacon and
enjoy it yeah so live a normal life but
that's not the advice I want to leave
with people watching this program the
the proper advice is you should not
smoke you should take your vitamins you
should exercise properly because
medicine is changing you know you have
to be around in order to benefit from
the coming singularity give a give a
short definition of that a singularity
is when things are accelerating so
rapidly it's not just exponentially
rising but it's almost like going up
vertically so that the rate of new
knowledge accumulation will allow Homo
sapiens our species to be able to make
such enormous progress scientifically
and technologically that we will be able
to solve all of the major problems that
are facing society today
including global warming and many of the
other questions of war and peace that
dominate the news headlines today so
again they're there avoiding cancer
they're avoiding heart disease but but
explain what it what's what ends up
getting that so I wondered is there
something that we could write on death
certificates
besides these conventional causes of
death like heart disease and cancer and
stroke and so we started doing a series
of autopsies so far I have done eight it
six of the eight so the majority have a
common disease process that is their
cause of death it's called amyloidosis
and it's a particular type called TTR
and all-caps turns out that amyloid
accumulates in all of us but very slowly
but when we do an autopsy of a younger
person it's typically found on the
certificate of death and the autopsy
report the necropsy says incidental
finding no it's a minor thing it didn't
kill the person but it's in the
background and so I'd like to think of
this as the Grim Reaper waiting in the
wings so that if he didn't get you with
something else he still has another way
to take a shot at you and amyloidosis is
something that has no cure today so one
of our foundations major interests is
finding out if there would be a targeted
therapy against this protein is there
something like an antibody that would be
specific for amyloid protein that would
clean out the blood vessels and then
maybe supercentenarians could live even
longer than they do now
that would answer a very important
scientific and medical question so
everybody will want to know you know
what what can I do to live a longer life
and I know a lot of it is genetics and
we mentioned that you should avoid
smoking and take your vitamins and so on
are there since you're an expert in this
field is there anything that isn't is
beyond the obvious like that people
would have overlooked there are in my
short list a couple of recommendations
one is that everybody should do a
certain amount of walking turns out that
exercise is a critical part of
maintaining your body function and
circulating blood to your brain people
should be taking a multivitamin and fish
oil and maybe increase their vitamin d3
level because that's the sunshine
vitamin and people don't get enough
exposure to sunlight yeah everybody is
not worried about getting the skin out
getting skin cancer and in the process
the pendulum swung too far and really
getting some is important and if you're
not and most people are not then just
taking a vitamin d3 supplement at the
level of eight hundred or a thousand
international units per day will be very
important as a way to contribute to your
longevity in reduce the risk and prevent
cancer
are there any reforms that we could put
in place to speed up the process of
innovation some people say maybe the FDA
is too risk-averse some people point to
patent protections being either too
protective or not protective enough well
I like the FDA to be risk-averse you
know one of the things that I credibly
have doesn't like you well yeah it slows
the rate of innovation to some extent
but it also stops crazy things from
happening which take place in the non
pharmaceutical nutraceutical field where
there is no regulation of companies that
are producing products that have a label
of ingredients in which when you do
product testing you discover there the
active ingredient is not even in the
bottle but right now the FDA tests for
safety and efficacy what if it yes just
zeroed in on safety and let the market
take care of the efficacy part might
that make things safe and still speed
things up I disagree I mean safety is
what we call a Phase one clinical trial
but there's a Phase two trial which
includes a broader collection
subjects to see if the product is safe
for children or is it safe for pregnant
women or things like that which is not
normally tested for in phase one the
German government approved fluid amide
as a sleeping pill because it was very
safe for the men and women who took it
but nobody was pregnant in that group
sure and then it turned out that there
were women who took it during like the
first or second trimester of pregnancy
and had babies that were born deformed
but that but everybody knows about
thalidomide baby and people don't know
about the people who could have been
helped by drugs that are kept off the
market so it does doesn't that well the
FDA knows about you know that these
risks ah let me explain they're not open
about them the FDA has different
guidelines for people who are near death
because of a lethal disease condition
and so they have something called
compassionate use of experimental drugs
and so people with you know very
debilitating diseases like cystic
fibrosis or other inherited conditions
that are doomed to die young could try
out some new experimental drugs so that
there is a safety valve so to speak to
keep the rate of innovation high I know
a topic that that's brought up on your
website quite a bit is immortality yes
how likely is that well that's a dream
after the year I don't know 20:38
when Kurzweil predicts there will be a
singularity maybe will redress that
problem in the meantime we have to
appreciate that there are really very
different aspects to immortality one is
death due to getting hit by a truck I
mean there are many ways to die
prematurely and so I call that extrinsic
aging it's not really an aging process
intrinsically in the body it's something
like a lightning bolt that came from
but the intrinsic aging process is
something that we can do something about
so maybe if we figure out how to solve
intrinsic aging then people will become
much more conservative and not drive on
freeways little bubbles that will be
bubble pop I don't know with the
internet doesn't seem to be true people
like their social media sure but they're
just gonna be yeah like you say a lot
more careful crossing the street maybe
yeah you'll take a little bit more care
in you know what you do and your
lifestyle and and I wonder what all the
Social Security actuaries think about
what you're doing I mean we're gonna
have to raise the retirement age to like
99 I think that people should be
appreciating that they shouldn't retire
at 65 if they're still healthy they
should be contributing to you know the
workforce and to our society by working
and not just imagining that they now
have the right to travel around the
world at somebody else's expense
you